ihr dabei seid es soll die schönste zeit
des jahres sein doch manchen graut schon
jetzt vor den feiertagen denn sie werden
zum beispiel am heiligabend oder an
silvester alleine sein wir wollen heute
über einsamkeit an weihnachten sprechen
und über eine initiative die dafür sorgt
dass möglichst niemand alleine sein muss
keiner bleibt allein so heißt sie und so
heißt auch der hashtag dazu und
irgendwie passend dazu bin ich auch
heute hier nicht allein im studio bei
mir ist nämlich der erfinder von keiner
bleibt allein christian find ich freue
mich sehr dass die heute hier sind
herein
vorerst müssen sie uns jetzt mal
erklären was genau verbirgt sich hinter
keiner bleibt allein hinterkante bleibt
allein verbirgt sich eine gesellschaft
ermittlungen letzten endes ist also wir
versuchen viele leute zueinander zu
bringen die ansonsten an weihnachten
oder an silvester beispielsweise alleine
werden und das funktioniert dann wie
genau soziale netzwerke wie funktioniert
das funktioniert über die drei größten
sozialen netzwerke in deutschland
ausgemacht haben wo wir auch gewusst
haben diesen einfach für die leute zu
bedienen facebook instagram und twitter
und ja darüber versuchen wir die leute
letzten endes miteinander zu vernetzen
und direkt gingen oder vorzustellen
also soweit die theorie und wir gucken
uns jetzt erst mal an wie das dann in
der praxis aussieht
christian döll erinnert sich noch gut an
die zeit vor zwei jahren nach der
trennung von seiner frau festtage ohne
familie in heidelberg und große
einsamkeit
zufällig stieß er bei twitter auf keiner
bleibt allein ein projekt gegen
einsamkeit das zwischen menschen
vermittelt die gesellschaft bieten und
denen die sie suchen
hab mich dann dafür angemeldet also die
gedanken waren natürlich von daya passt
das jetzt wird man sich gut unterhalten
können sind die leute in ordnung
sofort wurde ich begrüßt man hatte
sofort ein herzliches warmes gefühl
einfach seine gastgeber am
silvesterabend carina zeit und mike
beckers ihre familie und freunde wohnen
weit weg die drei verstehen sich auf
anhieb
wir haben uns vorher auch schon auf
twitter ein bisschen beschnuppern können
also wir kannten den countdown zumindest
schon mal und kommen so ein bisschen die
interessen aushorchen und ja dann war es
einfach so das experiment was uns auch
gereizt hat einsamkeit kann nicht fertig
machen
vor zwei jahren begann die initiative
mit 2300 anfragen vor allem von jüngeren
dieses jahr sind es bisher zehn mal so
viel
keiner bleibt allein ist weder ein
dating noch ein ratgeber portal
es geht vor allem um unbeschwerte
begegnung sagte initiator mein eigener
anlass dieses gewisse kunden war erst
mal dass ich im dezember 2016 selbst
seine einsamkeit situation hatte und
dann im dezember 2017 wieder erkannt
habe dass ganz ganz viele menschen da
sind die man eben tatsächlich zueinander
bringen kann
christian mike und carina treffen sich
seit silvester 2017 regelmäßig wir haben
jetzt zahlt das trübt das ist wirklich
gepasst hat als als hätte dass so ein
matching system zusammengefunden auch
von den interessen kneipe grillen
konzerte sie sind freunde geworden habe
auch schon überlegt selbst als gastgeber
teilzunehmen weil ich einfach findet
dass es eine sehr interessantes und
spannendes projekt ist
und auch carina und mike überlegen noch
am silvesterabend haben sie in diesem
jahr noch keine festen pläne und bei mir
ist der erfinder von keiner bleibt
allein christian fein fein wenn es ja
gerade im beitrag gehört dass sie selber
auch schon mal persönlich mit einsamkeit
zu kämpfen hat man daraus ja so ein
bisschen die idee geboren ist wie war
das damals bei ihnen das war setzten
anderswo das ist eine ganz klassische
einsamkeit situation hatte also ich war
zu dem zeitpunkt frisch getrennt von
meiner frau aber man hat eben noch
gemeinsam in der wohnung gelebt und
dadurch ist dann meine frauen natürlich
daneben zu ihren eltern gefahren und ich
war letzten endes ja alleine in der
wohnung gewesen und dann habe ich mir
natürlich gedanken macht gekommen ist
denn da ist damit klar mit der situation
und ich habe dann twitter für mich
entdeckt habe dann auf twitter
angefangen leute dazu zu animieren dass
sie eben auch über dieses thema
einsamkeit zu heiligabend jetzt
beispielsweise was schreiben und einfach
sich mal gedanken darüber machen dass
man anstatt jetzt eben alleine zu hause
zu sitzen daneben gemeinsam versucht zu
auf twitter zu feiern
wenn jetzt jemand sich genau in so einer
ähnlichen situation befindet wie geht
man vor und wie findet man dann jetzt
bei ihnen hilfe der zu rücken zu uns ist
letzten endes relative einfach also wir
haben ist den menschen ermöglichen uns
letztens eine nachricht zu schicken
auf den größten sozialen netzwerke neben
facebook twitter und instagram und ja
dort dann eben beispielsweise bekannt zu
geben dass man entweder platz anbieten
möchte zu heiligabend aber dass man eben
einen platz zu heiligabend und wir
vermitteln dann eben die leute also wenn
sie jetzt beispielsweise aus bochum sind
dass sich da jemand gemeldet hat der
gastgeber ist und jemand der gast ist
dann stellen wir die beiden einander vor
und die beiden haben dann die
möglichkeit miteinander zu schreiben ob
es für den sie dann so vorstellt war es
letzten endes miteinander zu feiern oder
eben nicht
wie kommen übrigens schon ganz schön
viele kommentare hier schreibt zum
beispiel das ist ein ganz wichtiges
zeichen und niemanden niemand sollte
weihnachten allein
feiern und bettina zum beispiel schreibt
eine super idee sie sagt unfreiwillig
auch schon mal mehrere silvester nächte
alleine gewesen das wäre nicht besonders
schön gewesen
also es machen jetzt haben wir gerade
schon im beitrag gesehen immer mehr
leute mit
gibt es denn geschichten jetzt aus den
vergangenen jahren die ihm besonders in
erinnerung geblieben sind ja also da
haben wir mehrere wir haben jetzt
beispielsweise auch extreme
altersunterschied bei denen man auf den
ersten blick denken würde dass besonders
gut passen das war glaube ich dem raum
hessen gewesen
da hat meine 24 jährige junge dame und
der 75 jährige junge der junge dame in
dem sinne und die haben wir dann
nebeneinander vorgestellte hole gedacht
haben okay kann vielleicht eventuell
auch überhaupt nicht passen
die haben dann ein wunderschöner abend
miteinander verbracht ich glaube in
marburg war das ganze wo ich dann
gemeinsam weihnachtskonzert versucht
haben sind noch spazieren gegangen haben
noch zusammen kaffee getrunken und
hinweise auf das ist letzten endes jetzt
immer noch kontakt miteinander haben
also so alle zwei monate treffen die
sich einfach mal immer wieder unter das
haben wir es dann eben auch geschafft
sind dann wieder zu integrieren also im
prinzip eine generationsübergreifende
sache muss man sagen
und immer mehr machen mit sie habe es
gerade schon gesagt und wir haben heute
natürlich auch schon tagsüber als
angekündigt haben dass wir über dieses
thema sprechen viele kommentare bekommen
und da schauen wir jetzt mal rein
seit mein papa im februar gestorben ist
fällt auch weihnachten für mich aus ich
bin ganz froh dass ich ab 18 uhr taxi
fahren können
ja das problem habe ich jedes jahr
ich konnte es letztes jahr verschlafen
wenn das diesmal nicht klappt filme
sehen und vielleicht mag ja jemand mit
mir telefonieren
das ist so mein weihnachten ein tag wie
jeder andere
so ist das wenn man krank im bett liegt
und alleine ist mein mann ist
schichtarbeiter oft gehören mir die
feiertage allein
und die kommen schon die ersten
kommentare von euch von leuten die gerne
mitmachen wollen hier schreibt zum
beispiel nati ich biete gerne für
weihnachten ein oder zwei plätze an mit
einem smiley sind ein gutes zeichen und
ich will die frage einfach ihnen auch
ganz gerne stellen wie feiern sie denn
dieses jahr und sind irgendwo eingeladen
oder laden sie selber ein
diese also bei mir ist natürlich ein
bisschen komplexer dadurch der
hauptsächlich verantwortlich für das
projekt bin also ich hat heiligabend
selbst bis 17 uhr ganz ganz viel arbeit
haben also dass daneben auch die zeit in
der ich mir sagt er ist es wert so viele
letzten endes dann eben an arbeiten
hineinzulegen aber ich selbst werden an
heiligabend eben auch dadurch dass jetzt
nicht so christlich veranlagt bin
letzten endes bei der heilige unbedingt
feiern aber mit freunden auf jeden fall
zusammen verbringen
wir haben hier super viele positive
kommentare aber es gibt natürlich auch
leute die sagen für mich ist es nicht so
richtig was hier schreibt zum beispiel
wenn bei twitter nett gemeint aber für
leute wie ihn sei es eher
kontraproduktiv er wird sich anders
kennen und wer sogar ganz gerne allein
schreibt er hier damit komme ich super
klar
und hier schreibt anne hecht bei youtube
gute sache darf ich das geschlecht
meines babys frei wählen
na ja also es ist auf jeden fall immer
möglichst letzten endes ich sag es mal
gewisse vorlieben letzten endes mit
zugeben dass man jetzt beispielsweise
eben sagt also in den meisten fällen von
junge frauen dass sie dann natürlich
sagen okay sie hätten jetzt gerne keinen
herren beispielsweise als gastgeber und
wir versuchen dann auf jeden fall außen
darauf achten manchmal ist aber so dass
sie eben keine andere möglichkeit ergibt
da haben wir dann glücklicherweise die
situation ist jetzt beispielsweise ein
homosexueller herzig meldeten da dieses
durchaus okay
ja frauen kommen mit denen da halt eben
auch prima klar
frage wie ist denn das wenn ich
plötzlich ein treffen bei mir an
weihnachten unterm tannenbaum sitzen
habe genau und wie sein sonst dazu
entschieden zu sagen dass die menschen
einander letzten endes ersten mal
beschnuppern sollen auf eine gewisse art
und weise also nachrichten miteinander
schreiben oder gegebenenfalls noch
miteinander telefonieren um daneben
festzustellen kann man sich das
überhaupt vorstellen mit dieser fremden
person
letzten endes gemeinsam weihnachten oder
silvester zu feiern also das heißt im
prinzip gibt es erst mal eine phase eine
gewisse phase des kennenlernens und das
heißt nicht dass plötzlich jemand bei
ihm dann vor der haustür steht den man
gar nicht einschätzen könnten genau also
wir forcieren das auch nicht da hat
jeder jederzeit die wahl zu sagen ich
möchte das nicht
oder ja auch letzten endes vor der
vermittlung zurückzutreten weil das
passiert ja auch manchmal dass man dann
plötzlich doch von irgendjemandem
eingeladen wird zu weihnachten oder
silvester also das ist jetzt keine fixe
sache weil wir wissen jetzt es
zwischenmenschlich ganz ganz viel
passieren kann und vor allen dingen ist
ja auch der zeitraum in dem wir ja das
ganze anbieten das ist ja jetzt dieses
mal mitte november gewesen ist ja ein
ganz großer und in fünf wochen kann
einfach enorm viel passieren hier kommt
gerade eine frage von kit bei youtube
der fragt ob es nicht was ähnliches ist
wie ein dating service und das ist es ja
nicht oder genau ist eine
gesellschaftsentwicklung das machen wir
auch letzten endes ganz ganz vielen
leuten dann eben auch klar weil wir
haben ja keine profilierung wir können
nicht sagen
du kannst hier in diverse hobbys oder
ähnliches angeben sondern ja es ist
wirklich einfach dieses dass wir das
angebot haben dass wir einen anderen
menschen anbieten seien so annimmt wie
man denn eben ist
wir wollen noch einmal grundsätzlich
über dieses thema einsamkeit sprechen
denn irgendwie jeder kennt das ja am
samstagabend allein auf der couch das
finden die meisten jahr gar nicht so
schlimm aber an weihnachten alleine sein
dass es dann eben doch was ganz anderes
und dazu haben wir einen experten
befragt das liegt glaube ich ein
bisschen daran dass weihnachten so eine
vorstellung mit sich
vectron sonne von der idee von
familienfest zu sein also dass man an
weihnachten sich versammelt groß väter
großeltern verwandtschaft die kleinen
kinder springen herum usw alles
vorstellungen die auch von der werbung
unglaublich hoch gebaut und unterstützt
werden die aber mit der wirklichkeit
leider gottes wenig zu tun haben jetzt
aus ihrer persönlichen erfahrungen aus
den vergangenen zwei jahren wie
verbreitet ist das denn eigentlich dass
leute tatsächlich an so einem wichtigen
tag alleine sind
es ist schon relativ stark verbreitet
sage ich jetzt mal aber ist eben auch so
dass diese zeit eine der intensivsten
ist also jetzt gerade immer schon
erklärt worden gerade ist jetzt in einem
kleinen beitrag
die leute haben einfach ganz ganz große
schwierigkeiten damit umzugehen vor
allen dingen eben auch jüngere und
deswegen sind wir froh dass wir mit
diesem projekt ganz ganz viele junge
menschen letzten endes mit erreichen
können weil vorher gab es ja nur sagen
ist man die alters einsamkeit die auch
auf eine gewisse weise bekannt war
aber jetzt haben wir eben auch nur
situationen das ist auch eine jüngere
leute bei uns melden können das ist eben
nicht nur ältere betrifft hier wird eine
frage gestellt noch einmal zum vorgehen
und war fragt julia es gibt es nur in
deutschland auch in österreich in
deutschland österreich der schweiz und
luxemburg
und ja allen deutschsprachigen ländern
ok wunderbar und hier fragt jemand bei
youtube er geht es dabei sind projekt
nur um feiertage
vorrangig geht es bei dem projekt darum
dass wir versuchen menschen aus der
einsamkeit zu holen spricht wir werden
diese vermittlung unter dem jahr nicht
machen weil da hatten wir dann die
erfahrung gemacht dass das ganze nicht
funktioniert hat weil die leute einfach
keinen gemeinsamen kontext haben also
jetzt an weihnachten und silvester kann
man sich dazu entscheiden
man möchte jetzt gemeinsam feiern
deswegen muss man miteinander reden
ansonsten hätte man unterm jahr die
situation dass das einzige gemeinsam mit
thema das man hätte eben einsamkeit wäre
und dann ist es mit dem gespräch
natürlich sehr schwer überhaupt
irgendeinen konsens gefällt zu finden
gemeinsam
deswegen bieten wir unter dem jahr
versuchen wir informationsportal zu sein
wenn man einfach schwierigkeiten hat
wieder in die gesellschaft zu kommen
und ja zum jahresende ist ein
gewissermaßen unserem marketing aktion
bei der welt an die leute letzten endes
direkt vor andere offene menschen
stellen und hier kommt natürlich ganz
viel zuspruch markus schreibt ganz
toller mensch ganz tolle aktion weiter
so und hier kamen bei youtube auch noch
mal einen kommentar schöner aktion werde
mit meiner familie schauen ob wir auch
etwas anbieten werden und ich glaube das
gibt natürlich viele leute bei denen das
so ist die sagen ich selber bin jetzt
nicht allein aber ich hätte vielleicht
noch ein platz frei
wie gehe ich dann jetzt wenn ich jetzt
möchte sie ein livestream hier geguckt
habe am besten vor als nächstes als
nächstes werde das allerbeste also je
nachdem wo man daneben ist wie gesagt
twitter facebook oder instagram dass man
uns erst mal folgt natürlich und auf
jeden fall der nach er schreibt in der
man dann eben angibt ich komme aus xy
und biete eine gastgeberschaft an oder
man kann natürlich eben auch wenn man
gesellschaft sucht uns dann eben den
stadtnamen schreiben und ja dass man
eben letzten endes gesellschaft sucht
für silvester für weihnachten
und ganz wichtig wahrscheinlich immer
der hersteller mit keiner ab bleibt wie
man in drei stücke damit man es einfach
finden kann
wenn also den am besten nicht vergessen
wenn man jetzt selber was anbieten
möchte da fand ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich dass sie heute hier waren und
ich kann ihnen jetzt schon frohe
weihnachten wünschen schöne feiertage
und im prinzip kann ich euch das auch
schon wünschen denn das war jetzt der
letzte live stream in diesem jahr
wir sehen uns aber natürlich im neuen
jahr wieder und es würde mich sehr
freuen
bis dahin tschüss
der livestream gefallen hat dann gefällt
euch vielleicht auch dieser hier
da ging es um kinder und jugendliche die
in armut leben und wie ihnen geholfen
werden kann
oder ihr klickt euch mal hier rein da
ging es um die verrohung der
gesellschaft oder ihr klickt hier und
lasst uns ein abo das wird uns freuen